can i live for the rest of my life in
this relationship
as it is today and experience a
wonderful life
and experience the happiness the peace
the joy that i want to experience
is that possible in my current
relationship
if nothing changed from the way it is
today and if the answer is no
the question to ask is so therefore it
needs to change or i need to leave
what evidence do i have that this is
going to change
and that's a question you have to ask
very very soberly there's a bias judge
in here that wants to do what's
comfortable not what's going to make you
happy
and you have to be very careful of not
listening to that judge
[Music]
hey folks i'm michaela peterson and i am
so pleased to introduce matthew hussey
as my guest on episode number 103 of the
michaela peterson podcast
matthew hussey is a best-selling author
and the world's leading
dating advice expert for women with
millions of followers on youtube
instagram tick tock and social medias
also possibly the most hilarious
newsletter i am currently subscribed to
we had a great discussion about whether
some people are meant to be single or in
relationships
vulnerabilities in relationships
jealousy gaslighting
and more this episode will be
interesting for
anyone who wants to learn about
rejection gas lighting didn't know what
that was
and other related topics or to see the
world's
most flirty human being doing a podcast
i say that with admiration and love if
you do enjoy this episode
please don't forget to subscribe thank
you matthew for coming on the podcast
[Music]
matthew hussey welcome to my podcast
thank you for having me
i've been excited about this this should
be very good i have so many questions
uh and i've been following you for a
while so this should be good
before we before i'd like hammer you
with a whole bunch of questions
can you give a brief background about
who you are and what it is you do
yeah man i always worry about this
question because i never have a
i feel like a great answer for it i
started out
15 years ago with an organization that
was designed to
help women in their love lives uh you
know it was quite
it started out as a very practical kind
of experiment which was
you know women have a lot of questions
for their love lives that don't seem to
be
being answered by cosmopolitan
so you know can i actually be of more
help
and you know i read a lot of women's
books uh on dating and relationships
and i found some of it to be
questionable in its approach and so i
started to take a different approach
that was just very practical
very logical to how women could get
better results in their love lives
everything from
finding uh a person attracting them
and having a great relationship that
put me on a journey of coaching and to
tell you the truth it was never really
dating that was my
passion it was people and it gave me a
platform
uh that built quite quickly through my
20s
and that's allowed me to reach a lot of
people with ideas and now i'm in
the privileged position of being able to
not have to talk about dating constantly
and still have an audience even when i'm
not
and and that's what i enjoy doing today
is empowering people
uh in all sorts of of areas of their
lives but i
in that area i wrote a new york times
best-selling book and there's been
millions of people that have
come and seen my work and so you know
that's all it's been kind of a wild 15
years
it's been 15 years so did you start
because you just saw an area or was
there something that triggered the
interest in helping women attract men
no that wasn't i i started
i mean here's the thing i started when i
was 11. i i my dad was a crazy like
entrepreneur uh he's still around
he's not past tense but he was a an
entrepreneur we had our ups and downs
but whether we were living in a house or
a trailer he always had books
and when i was 11 years old he he had a
book on his shelf
called how to win friends and influence
people which of course everyone knows
but when i was 11 i didn't know that
everyone knew that book i
i thought i discovered some kind of
secret scroll
that only i had access to and i read it
and i i
i loved it i mean i loved this idea that
you could be better at
with people that it wasn't you weren't
just condemned
to however shy or introverted you
thought you were and i was both
as a kid so that kind of sent me on a
path when i was 14 my friend's dad
dragged his son to a tony robbins
seminar
and i being the friend of
of this guy got dragged too but i wasn't
really having to be persuaded because
i was already into those kinds of books
and so i went along and that became the
kind of really
yeah and it became this marriage of
some of the content i was reading with
the performance aspect of it someone who
had an incredible
you know whatever you you think of tony
robbins love hate whatever
that person has an extraordinary
charisma on stage
and that then became this
this marriage of the two that set me on
a path quite early
not that i thought i was gonna do that i
mean i was you know studying real estate
at university
but i i knew i was interested in that
world and i was looking for any
opportunity to help people
and i'd coached guys from 19 years old
i was doing one-on-one coaching i
remember going into london and seeing a
seminar where guys were coaching
other guys on how to talk to women and
it was a weird
underground strange world but
even at the time i was like well this is
a stage that at least i can get on
there you know no one's going to let me
on no one
at dale carnegie and i know because i
went there at 16 and asked to go on
stage for them
uh they weren't gonna let me on stage so
if i found this kind of strange little
underworld
in london of people coaching other
people i realized
oh i might actually get some time
coaching people even if it's four or
five people
and that's where it started for me was
helping men
and then at 20 i had the idea that well
no one seems to be doing a great job of
this for women yeah so
i'll start helping women so when you're
coaching people
just say for the man the men aspect
where you're teaching
men how to pick up women does that end
up translating to the rest of their
relationship or are there just like
tricks you learn and then you can pick
up women but then after
six months some of these tricks wear off
and you have to
figure out you know how to have a
personality or something that's a
fascinating question because
it's it's kind of
interesting to me that different
different
phases of a relationship require such
different skills and
the the act of having to walk over to
someone
who you don't know i mean of course now
we have apps and so on
but when i started my company i that was
it was very much
the world of no dating apps you had to
go and do something
the idea of walking over to a stranger
that you don't know
with the intention of picking them up
man or woman
is an intensely scary thing for most
people
and one that's even scarier for people
today because they're
15 years out of practice or they were
born into a world where they've never
had to do that
and it's kind of it's extraordinarily
unique
to the first five minutes of your life
with someone
so it's not a skill that you necessarily
have to be good at again
after that and okay yeah fair and so now
you meet someone and you get into a
relationship
you're now into a different skill set
which is
showing up for someone being a great
teammate being a great partner
knowing how to get through hard times
together hopefully
you don't lose all of what made you
attractive in the first two weeks
because i
i am a big believer that what made you
attractive in the first two weeks
is still a key to what will make you
attractive in year two and year four and
year ten
i think people losing that idea is part
of the reason why relationships go
stale and and die but yeah you're right
it's a different it's a completely
different skill set and that's why
people who find themselves to be
men or women i coach who find themselves
to be single again
after many years out of the game so to
speak
hate that part most of them
like you mean i've gotta go and talk to
a stranger again and put myself
through this this is a horrible thing
for most people to have to put
themselves through
huh okay most people want a relationship
but they don't want to date
that's fair i don't think i ever had
that problem to be honest
going you yeah maybe
maybe too much probably i wasn't worried
about that kind of thing at all
which is interesting that's really
amazing where do you think that comes
from for you
because i was the opposite i was quite
afraid
i didn't i mean the worst
that could happen in that kind of
situation where somebody says no didn't
seem that bad
like what are they gonna say turn like
what are they gonna do turn me down
like oh well it does so that amount of
fear i guess just
didn't disturb me for whatever reason
i have no idea i i suppose that most
people
you know including myself at that time
equate that rejection with that
with our own worth you know with yeah if
i if if you rejected me it must mean i'm
hideous
uh okay so i didn't have that i just had
oh well they're lost
so maybe just grandiose that's selfish
pretty amazing that's pretty amazing
thank you thank you very much maybe how
i grew up
who knows this episode is brought to you
by true local
true local partners with local farmers
and butchers in your area to source the
best meat and deliver to your door
meat like 100 grass-fed and
grass-finished beef
pasture-raised or raised without
antibiotics chicken
or wa lamb bison and more eating
healthily is so
important for attracting people trying
to make it relevant
to this episode guys but seriously
eating meat makes you more attractive
hands down there are studies on that
on men there are i recommend they're
grain-fed beef
wild salmon and their lamb is some of
the best i've had
look at this baby look at this
they also have 100 different cuts of
meat that you can't find at your grocery
store
probably depending on where you live in
the boonies definitely not
to get started just go to truelocal.ca
for canadians
and that's tru local dot ca for
canadians or trulocalusa.com for
americans to build your own personalized
box oh meat shows up at your door vacuum
sealed
individually portioned like so by an air
fryer also
just throw those stakes in the air fryer
flip them once the laziest way to cook
it works so well
and use codemp to get free steak in your
order
at truelocal.ca or truelocal.com codemp
enjoy the rest of the episode uh do you
think do you think some people are
destined to be single
are people supposed to be in
relationships
i don't know that i think
i was just talking i would literally
just
did an episode of my podcast right
before this and we were talking about
that idea of is one better than the
other
should should we aspire to one
particular state
and we do live in a world culturally
societally where
it it still seems to be that
the undertone is still
why are you still single that carries it
carries that message that there's
somehow something wrong with you if you
are
and and i really worry about that
because i
i mean not least of which because i work
with literally thousands of women a
month
who are making bad decisions
based on that idea of their value
that they're somehow not as worthy
or they haven't achieved enough if they
don't find themselves in a relationship
or they don't find themselves
with children and it i you know i saw
the the interview that you guys did you
and your dad with russell brand
and there was a a moment in that
interview where your dad said something
that was
very interesting from my lens
because i i have a different
i suppose just a dif i've had a
different
perspective for the last 15 years and he
said
you know he didn't feel that someone
could really
truly grow up unless they had children
yeah
which is obviously a bold statement
which your dad is not known for of
course
i i i am i heard that and i and i
actually
intrinsically i understood what was
meant by it i i
i truly do i come from the perspective
where i've
i've dealt with probably ironically as a
as a man who doesn't have children and
who isn't a woman
i have dealt with more
women than probably most people on earth
ever have or will who are grieving the
fact
that they have missed their moment to
have
their own biological children
and so i see the um i see the pain
the terrible terrible pain that comes
with that and i'm very close and
intimate with that
in my profession and i
also deal with an incredible number of
people who are made to
feel like a failure because they're not
in a relationship
and i think it's it's really really
damaging to
people's not only their confidence but
their
ability to be happy with their current
lot
in life and and why what i don't like
about the cultural thing of
you know you're more successful if
you're in a relationship is that
i deal with people every day who become
instantly more successful the moment
they leave a relationship
because they shouldn't be in that
relationship it's toxic it's abusive
yeah they settled for something that's
far less than they deserve
and so success to me is leaving it's not
staying but
when we get constantly indoctrinated
with this idea that
that being in a relationship or having a
stereo stereotypical path in life
is success we start to make really bad
decisions
yeah i suppose it's an interesting
conversation as to whether there is just
whether there is just a higher like
there's a hierarchy where
you know there is an ultimate state that
is
just objectively better than the others
but um i don't know if thinking that way
does us any favors in our decision
making
in the moment yeah yeah i think you're
right
um how do you know when it's better to
leave
a relationship and deal with the
loneliness
of being alone how do you know when
that's a better option than
staying i
i suppose what we want to look at
is
am i basing
if we stay and we're really unhappy
then we must on some level
be basing that decision to stay
on the premise that this is going to
improve that this person is going to be
better
yes that this person or this situation
is going to change
and i said perhaps the most pertinent
question to ask ourselves is
um what evidence am i basing this on
this idea that it's going to change or
that this person is going
to change what is this based on
you know when a woman for example let's
take the scenario of
someone just broke your heart they just
decided
i don't want to be here anymore i'm out
and you didn't see it coming
but they left and then two weeks later
they come back and they say wait wait
wait i was all wrong i don't know what i
was thinking
i i i love you to pieces i i i want to
be in a relationship with you
okay maybe give him a chance let's say
it happens again a month later
and then they break up with you two
weeks later they come back oh my god i
made the biggest mistake
at that point it's actually really
important to ask the question of that
person in a
very sober way not in an emotionally
charged way
what is it that is going to be
different this time and why like
why would it be different this time and
and i don't mean asking it from a place
of
anger i mean sincerely being curious
what's the plan here for more certainty
because you seem very uncertain
you seem to not know what you want and
from my vantage point it seems very
likely this is going to happen again
in the next three to six months so
what's different for you now other than
you got panicked
in the two weeks after you just did this
again
in a relationship where two people are
trying to make it work
you have to ask what evidence is there
for the fact that this is going to make
it work
it's going to work are we together in
therapy
are we working through it have we
genuinely made a plan about how we're
going to work through this issue
are we communicating and there's genuine
progress in the communication
because that's the part where
we consistently ignore the fact that we
haven't actually had any signs that this
is really going to change
and yet we go i just feel like it can be
better
based on what not based on them
based on whatever fantasy you're
constructing in your head about it
being better so it's can i live with
this
the key questions of these can i live
for the rest of my life in this
relationship
as it is today and experience a
wonderful life
and experience the happiness the peace
the joy that i want to experience
is that possible in my current
relationship
if nothing changed from the way it is
today
and if the answer is no the question to
ask is
so therefore it needs to change or i
need to leave
what evidence do i have that this is
going to change
and that's a question you have to ask
very very soberly
there's a bias judge in here that wants
to do what's comfortable not what's
going to make you happy
and you have to be very careful of not
listening to that judge
okay what if you're not unhappy but
you're just not happy
like what does unhappy look like
exactly is that like obvious misery
because i feel like those are
the relationships where you're like okay
i'm out of here this is definitely not
working
but it's the ones where you're like okay
this isn't working but you know
maybe it'll get better it's not that bad
i don't know if there's anything better
out there
what do you do then acute you're right
acute pain is useful because it
can force action the low level
chronic pain is
um more insidious in some ways be it
emotional or physical
i mean yeah the emotional
side of it is that you can convince
yourself you can
live with it but even
even with let's say chronic physical
pain as a
as a metaphor even with that
you can kind of live with it for so many
days or months or
years until you get to a point where
you and i know you talk a lot about
physical pain and i'm fa
i love listening to you on that subject
by the way i'm like whenever whenever i
see your clips on instagram and things
cut up from you talking about these
subjects i know you have so much
experience with it
um i love it i love chronic pain
experience
yeah well i just love how you talk about
it in such a raw and real way and i have
to say i admire
i really admire the rawness and the
authenticity that you bring
to your communication publicly because i
know that's not easy and it's
amazing um but i thank you
i i when it comes to chronic pain
we can we can deal with it for so many
days until
it becomes something where we go it's
almost a moment where we admit to
ourselves like
this is a problem yeah this isn't this
isn't
life well lived like i am con this is
so ever present in my life
that it it may not make me
suicidal in every moment but it
certainly is like taking away any
enjoyment i could have out of this life
and and that becomes i think a certain
crescendo of pain
at a particular point and i think that's
true in a relationship
too emotional the chronic
uh the chronic pain of not getting your
needs met
is something you can sustain for a
certain amount of time before you look
at that expanse of time and go
on what level was i really living during
that time
and and do i really want to live like
that forever because maybe this
relationships have this unique ability
to poison
other parts of our lives when they're
going wrong you know we can kind of
leave
a bad day at work and go back home to
our family or our relationship and
and escape when when things are wrong in
our relationship
unless we are the most incredible
compartmentalizers
that for me personally i can't i'm not
good at compartmentalizing in that way
if i have a fight with my girlfriend or
if something
i carry that with me into the day
and it affects me and it creates anxiety
and it creates
so you know it can poison everything
else and
and that's what you have to look at is
the unhappiness i feel in this
relationship
i may be convincing myself it's
contained to this
area of my life but actually it's
probably infecting me everywhere
and and i'll bet if we really look at it
it's infecting everything else too
i was in a relationship where i was
incredibly unhappy and
and i was lying to myself about how
unhappy i was
and my publisher met with me one day
and she was we were doing an interview
together and
i was interviewing her and she's an
amazing wonderful woman she's been a
kind of mentor to me in my life
and she left the interview and she
didn't tell me this
until the relationship ended but
she was with her sister at the time they
left the interview went off
she said i saw you that day and i looked
at my sister when we left and i said
he is not happy
like something is wrong like he's not
good
and i didn't realize just how much i was
telegraphing that
to the people that that knew me and how
much worse
energy they were getting as a result of
me being unhappy so that i would say
is fine saying it's bearable but you
have to
you know you have to look at the true
cost
of staying where it's comfortable
because
you probably haven't really assessed
that if you're still where you are right
now
okay that's reasonable do you think
if you're in that kind of situation
there's a way to step back to
look at the situation without you know
being in it
and take a vacation or maybe have some
time apart and then look at it
is there a way to speed up the process
of realizing you're
not happy that's a great question
i think that you have to
i do think that space helps
in whatever form it comes you know it's
not always easy to just
up and take a vacation and get space but
maybe even just the space of
when we're not happy we tend to slowly
isolate
and we stop seeing certain friends
especially the friends that
are telling us things we don't want to
hear
we stop seeing that person gradually or
we go and see that person but we no
longer talk about our relationship with
them
because we know that if we talk about it
they're going to say something that's
going to upset us
it's going to poke at some deep part of
us that feels the truth of it and that's
not we don't want that truth
so our cognitive dissonance needs us to
distance ourselves
from certain people i think that i think
that continuing to invite
kind of in the same way that we you know
people like you and i do and your dad
does and
you know people who like debate people
who like who
want to hear other ideas who don't want
to be in their echo chamber
you have to put yourself around other
conversations and and i think that
that's actually an important thing to do
in your relationship if you're not happy
go listen to the people who are pointing
out something you don't want to hear
hear what they have to say spend time
with those friends and those family
members
do the brave thing of not isolating from
people who are pointing out things you
don't like
okay that makes sense i like that okay
i'm switching i'm switching the topic up
a little bit
i've seen some clips you have on
narcissism could you tell me
how to detect a narcissist
i see i feel in some ways underqualified
in this area because you know i think of
when i think of narcissism
as a psychological term that obviously
some people have studied
at depth um you know i i
they obviously can give you the
diagnosis diagnosable
traits of a narcissist i
i i worry about our culture of
like we have a culture right now that
seems to just diagnose everybody with
narcissism
yes immediately yes and i have
in my comment section you say you know i
can't make a video about a guy doing a
selfish thing without the comments being
like
he's a narcissist and i'm like well hang
on like we there have to be degrees
here it can't just be that we that we
label everyone a narcissist
what but but i do think that we all have
narcissistic tendencies
um i think all of us show those things
in different moments of our lives
uh the question is whether it becomes
clinical or is clinical with someone
that we're dealing with
i look for things like can someone
actually
can someone actually say they're sorry a
very simple thing
but can someone say that can someone say
you're right
that wasn't what i did wasn't great that
wasn't a that wasn't a good thing to do
or that was a selfish thing to do or can
they reflect
and have the self-awareness of knowing
that they did something that
wasn't okay or at the very minimum
was an intensely hurtful thing to do
or was ignorant or showed a lack of
understanding and acknowledge that and
apologize
for that i i really
and i don't think people who don't
apologize are
automatically narcissists but it's but i
do
think that it's one of those character
traits that
it would it freaks me out being around
people who can't apologize
because that's fair yeah that then you
kind of can't work with that person
you you know there's people you can be
with someone who does a lot wrong
but if they can acknowledge themselves
and be aware and and make a commitment
to be better
or to be more understanding or whatever
it is that needs to change
you can work with that person that's
like a partner you can actually work
with
but someone who can't acknowledge
what's what they did wrong or where
their flaws are and can't apologize
that's a problem and if on top of that
where that where it becomes particularly
insidious and the term that's also very
much
in psychological vogue right now is
gaslighting okay what if someone can you
please
please please tell me what that is
because i've heard that so many times
i've been like i have to look into that
everyone's saying gaslighting i have no
idea what it means
so thank you for bringing that up yeah
what is that is the
it's the term given to
when you make someone feel crazy
for something reasonably a term i should
have
known rational and logical that they are
saying
you know it's it's making someone feel
like they're not
not saying i disagree with you but but
going a step further
and making them seem like they're
completely nuts
like if i if if you
if you and i spoke three days from now
and
you referred to something in this
conversation that i absolutely said
and i said i never said that ah
and you you say what do you mean you
you don't i never said that
you said that you had this whole opinion
you made a big thing of it
no you completely i don't know where
you're getting that you completely
you're completely off i don't know where
you got that if i'm making you see
now you start to question your sanity
and you start to go
wait did he say maybe i maybe i did miss
here am i
you start and the real insidious thing
about gaslighting is that
it it erodes your self-esteem
and your belief in in your perception of
of life
you literally and and often people who
have been gaslighted
have the experience of getting out of a
relationship
and then finding out a whole bunch of
things about their partner
you know it's like they saw this thing
they didn't like it and they were like
wait this seems inappropriate and that
seems inappropriate and that seems
inappropriate and the whole time this
person is going
you're crazy you're crazy and then they
get out of the relationship and
realizing this person had
was having an affair all along but was
gaslighting them the entire time
that's that's not particularly spiteful
and nasty
okay so it's it's lying but it's a very
specific type of lying where you make
the other person think they're crazy
right okay that's interesting
oh i'm really glad i know that now i
don't know why i haven't googled that
before i should definitely know what
that
what that meant it's a word that i've
come to kind of eat
it's like a yeah i kind of it comes up
so much that it gets annoying but
it is actually a real thing that
so many people who make other people's
lives miserable
do yeah okay fair enough
what did you say you called it vogue
psychology vogue
psychological vote psychological vogue
that's fun okay um just out of curiosity
how are people meeting people nowadays
like are there certain apps or is it all
like instagram dms
or what are the popular ways of meeting
people now that the world got shut down
for a few years
yeah i well the thing is apps were
already that was already the number one
game in town as far as meeting
people and and and then you had the
people who are on the fence
and and like i don't want to use the
apps i hate the app so they've had bad
experiences they were burnt
out from using the apps yeah and
then of course covert hit and anyone who
was on the fence
kind of didn't have a choice if they
were single they were stuck in their
house and the
apps were the only way to meet someone
so the app companies
it was kind of like it was perfect for
them because
it just whoever was on the sidelines
got brought in at that point um and yeah
i mean
i don't have a problem with the apps per
se
i mean there are definitely problems
they create
problems as well as solving them you
know it doesn't do any favors for
our kind of attraction circuitry to
on one hand it's incredibly useful to be
able to sit in your pajamas
and meet someone in a neighboring town
like how could you do that before i as
an introvert
there's a part of me that loves the idea
that you don't have to actually leave
the house to meet people
have you taken just wait side note have
you had a personality test done i have
to ask you this because
i have so many people who come on
they're like yeah i have
millions of followers but i'm
introverted really are you sure
yeah if you saw my life you wouldn't
question it
okay i am really like
uh i'm i really enjoy my own company
and i'm i'm someone who when people ask
me
i just know from the evidence of my life
that i very much have to be cajoled and
persuaded
or persuade myself into doing things
that involve
other people um i and i love people
i really do i love people i i i love
being on stage because
there's a separation i i i get far away
from the people
yeah i can you know and i find the part
of an event
where everyone comes and says hello to
me and it's lovely i don't
i'm not complaining at all but the part
where there's a line of people
coming over to me i find in some ways
harder than the time when i'm on stage
nothing i heard stephen fry once say
like there's nothing he hates more than
a party
and and i sort of relate
to that and that's not to say like i
i've had
there are certain parties i'm at and i'm
like i'm having the time of my life this
is great but normally that's because
there's great music and i like dancing
it's not because i'm so enjoying all of
the small talk i'm having with random
people at this party that to me if my if
my like
mum or someone is like invites me to a
wedding of a family member i don't
really know
that's my nightmare okay
i'm i'm convinced that's funny because i
would say i
care for people but i don't really like
people but i'm very extroverted
like the average person i i don't get
along with very well or something
but i i like being around an interesting
combination so white youtube very
difficult yeah for people but you
you don't like them i don't really it's
very it's been
like difficult since i was a teenager i
was like ah [ __ ] i hate people
but i really like being around them and
i'm caring if i care if they're
suffering
but i think maybe it's irritable i think
perhaps i'm just
slightly irritable yeah i would sort of
describe myself
a little bit yeah like that too
i do you if i saw you at a party would
do you think that
i would experience you as as
uh not liking people easily or do you
think you'd come across as very warm and
friendly and
kind yeah very warm and friendly for
sure so you just i do
it's just a weird love-hate relationship
i think i maybe just don't appreciate
people whining about things
i think if i really needed to pinpoint
it it would be that
anyway i don't know how we got
sidetracked into that
i like hearing about it it's interesting
okay okay but i do
but i do i do understand where that
question comes from because that's yet
another thing where it seems popular
these days for everybody to say they're
an introvert
and i i have the same i have the same
feeling a lot
where you go are you really an introvert
or is it just that sometimes you like to
be alone and you're calling yourself an
introvert
yeah i think at different things i think
there are some people who are actually
introverted though
and end up growing a following because
they're super open and sometimes if
you're
a super open individual that kind of
covers your introversion
you usually don't have someone that's
like low in openness
and introverted and then they'll hang
around other people but sometimes
being high in openness can make you look
like an extrovert
right yeah i love i love sharing ideas
with people
i don't love the initial conversations
where you
are talking about nothing and and i also
i really love i really love spending
time with like one or two
i like i have three or four really close
friends in la
and i love spending time with them
i but when someone i don't know very
well asks me somewhere
i have to conv and by the way some of
the best experiences i have are from
saying yes
so i have i'm not saying i don't ever do
it i
sometimes i get myself to say yes
because i'm like i'm all i never regret
expanding my
life and expanding my circle and
bringing new people into my world
but i my god do i have to do a
persuasion
mission on myself to get myself to do it
okay
interesting do you know anything about
the love languages
is there anything to that yeah
i well i i think any kind of heuristic
that
that makes people love a model
they love like the five love languages
really effectively created a model
by which people could put a
a a an easy language to the way they are
so you know the
you know you can say oh i'm you know
touch is my love language my number one
love language or
you know it's quality time is my number
one love language and it kind of it just
gives you this nice neat framework to
put to the way that you are and i think
those things are
are very useful when applied practically
in a relationship because it allows you
to ask a simple question
it gives you a language to kind of look
at
communication with your partner you can
say ah so my partner is more
you can even ask them which what would
you say is your love language and by
hearing them out and by
maybe even observing because sometimes
people tell you it's this but then you
realize they light up every time you do
this so it's like oh actually probably
this is more your love language
you can then actually serve them better
and be a better partner so i think that
it's very useful from
from that point of view but of course
models you know it's like the
there's you know the other model that
people quote a lot is attached the
the book about different attachment
styles and
can we get into that slightly i haven't
heard of that i don't know the book
about it there's a there's a book
attached which which references
different attachment styles there's
insecure
no there's anxious attachment style
secure attachment style
um and avoidant and the
the idea is that i suppose it the kind
of
the the caricatured version of it would
be anxious attachment style needs a lot
of love and validation and reassurance
uh and is worried someone's going to
leave and abandon them the secure
attachment style is just very
comfortable in their skin
um doesn't react you know to arguments
in a way where they immediately feel
like
if you have an argument oh my god you're
going to leave me um
they're they're secure in the
relationship and in themselves and in
their ability to perhaps even deal with
it
if the relationship goes away uh the
avoidant
is someone who is
you know literally any when things get
too intense
too intimate when they feel too much
commitment when they
feel like all of that what that could
entail they
they need their space they need to to
create
distance so that they can feel like they
can breathe
um and none of these things
the idea of this i suppose is that none
of these things are inherently
just a bad thing and it's not that we
should spend our lives
trying to change our attachment style
but we should at least understand our
attachment style
and figure out how to work with it
and also help our partner understand how
to work with it
and ideally choose a partner who soothes
rather than agitates our attachment
style um but but again like that's a
that's a useful model
but where it gets confusing is
you can be you know
life isn't as simple as this is your
attachment style
yeah because a we grow and evolve but b
you can be really secure
attachment style in one relationship
yeah because you're in a safe
relationship and then you can be
in this passionate wild crazy
relationship with someone who
is constantly making you feel anxious
and insecure and and is like you never
know what's coming around the corner
and all of a sudden you find yourself
anxious all the time and you go i've
never been this person in a relationship
before what's happening to me right now
so it changes even between relationships
okay that's what i was gonna say
sounds like a toxic relationship and a
not toxic relationship potentially
um right how do you judge if a
relationship is healthy
if you end up getting into one of those
passionate relationships where
you're head over heels in love with
somebody but you're also kind of anxious
all the time trying to
please them how do you know when
that kind of relationship can be good
like
is the passion a bad thing sometimes how
do you identify when it's a good thing i
know that was a whole bunch of questions
but
well the problem is that when that
when it's good that's like
it feels the best i mean it's
like the you just took a hit i mean you
kind of did just take a hit of something
you know you have in those moments all
these chemicals flooding your brain and
and it's you are you are quite literally
on a high
and so it's some it's the best and then
it goes just as far in the other
direction the
the nadir of that is just
gruesome when all of a sudden you're
worried they don't love you
or that they're going to leave you or
that how will i ever survive
without this person it it then
feels like it it's death so
to me you know you've you've already put
someone in a position
that you're making your happiness far
too dependent
on them and you're probably overvaluing
them
you know that you're in order to feel
that way in order to feel just
sick with love you
have to be overvaluing something
you have to be because this isn't the
only great person in the world
there are other amazing people on this
earth there
you didn't you you weren't that lucky
that you found the only awesome person
there is
and and they decided to like you them
liking you
isn't unique because guess what they
like you because you're attractive
they like you because you have great
qualities that's why they like you it
wasn't an
accident you didn't that you know you
didn't win them
in some charity auction where they were
like well i guess
you know i'm going to love this person
out of charity now you
they they like you because there's
something attractive about you that's
not unique to them
other people are going to feel that way
too and
the attraction you feel for them isn't
that unique either there's
there are going to be other amazing
people in this world if you can stay
open to them
that alone should be some kind of
antidote to that love sickness because
we realize that what i'm doing here is
i'm deifying
this person and and
now this behavior which really sadly
becomes a departure from ourselves it
you know when we're serving up grapes
and wine to this deity that we've
created and we're doing
anything we can to please them and go
out of our way for them and bend over
backwards and
relinquish our own standards in order to
be closer to them or
to see them on their terms all the time
or constantly compromising our calendar
to suit theirs and yeah we're at that's
not
us it's like an it's like a super nice
person
like the person who's super nice all the
time
who's like effectively effectively nice
like they're
they're you know it doesn't make sense
how nice they are all the time and it
doesn't come from kindness it comes from
ego it comes from wanting everyone to
love them that's not real either
and the person who's a people pleaser in
a relationship you're literally not
being yourself
so now the person that this person is
with isn't even you
it's a it's a completely different
fabricated person
and and if you were in power you
wouldn't be acting this way
so you feel like you're not in power so
in order to
have some kind of power i've got to make
this person reliant on me or dependent
on me or i've got to do something
crazy and wild and keep this person
energized and interested
that that's not a relationship you'd
want for the rest of your life so we
almost have to like when we feel
that way take a breath and say
if i can't truly be me in this
relationship
then this is going to be a really
miserable life so there's no point white
knuckling it right now to hold on to
them
because i wouldn't want to live that way
for the rest of my life so
let me be me right now a a great me
but let me be me and see if that's
enough
for this person and if it's not enough
for this person
then i don't need to worry i didn't lose
what i thought i lost
and that's the great fear the great fear
is we're going to lose something we were
supposed to have
this person is amazing and they're the
best person i'll ever meet and this
i'm supposed to be with this person not
if not if it doesn't work out you're not
like if in year two someone breaks up
with you it wasn't supposed to be a
five-year relationship doesn't matter
what you did
but it doesn't matter what you were
trying to someone by definition
the person who leaves you was not the
person you were supposed to have
it's like it literally becomes an act of
of science fiction to say they broke up
with me but
that was my person evidently not
i like that is there any way to have a
relationship that has those highs
without having them
also have the lows like or is that
kind of passion just toxic
always
i think that we want to check ourselves
you know when we're when we're feeling
when we're feeling immense joy and
appreciation and
and love for somebody it has to be
tempered by the fact that i would be
okay
even if i didn't have this like this is
amazing
but but i should always be feeding
my life in a way that makes my life
amazing
and myself amazing i don't mean like you
have to achieve
so that not measuring it by some just
external standard of achievement but
i have to keep building myself and how
proud i am of myself
in life anyway so that if this goes away
i'm still left with someone i really
love and am proud of
and i you know there are parts of my
life that give me sort of giddy
highs sometimes when i'm going on stage
when i'm touring when i'm
that when i make a great video and
everyone loves it and i'm like you know
i find myself
you know i've always have to suspect
myself
when i didn't just read the comments
once but i went back for more five times
today to see what the new ones were
like if i was just trying to get a
temperature on whether the video did
well or not did it resonate with people
then i'd go check read some comments and
be like oh this is really resonating
people are really enjoying this that's
great
that's informative if for the sixth or
seventh or eighth time today i'm going
back and refreshing
to see the next five comments the next
ten
now i have to suspect myself because i
know already
i'm setting myself up for a full i know
that if
now here's the danger now i'm making
videos every week
if i get too attached to the validation
i just got from that video
that's going to inform my next video
now my next video i'm not creating
because i really feel like
wow there's this new thing i really want
to say that i think is going to help
people
i'm making i'm trying to make a video
that gets as many great comments as the
last video
and now i'm departing from myself yeah
and and what's authentic already
you can apply that same thing to a
relationship
that's how people get stuck in echo
chambers too because they make something
and everybody
loves it whoever their audience is
absolutely loves it and they're like oh
well if i just keep doing that
it'll just keep working and then i think
that's how people get stuck without
wanting to piss off their audience ever
and then like you said
yeah they stopped being as truthful
right i always liked
even though he might be you know
have some severe mental health issues i
also liked kanye for that reason
i always loved that i like every album
i always truly respected him as an
artist because every album he brought
out
risked losing everyone that came with
him on the last one like he just
made unique things artistically instead
of pandering to the last thing he made i
always thought that was
unbelievably brave yeah i agree or he's
or he's just wired for that and it's not
something
that's easy for the rest of us to
replicate apart from you
who seem to have no problems ever going
up to someone attractive and asking them
out
this is true this is very true okay you
might be wired like kanye in the best
way oh
god i hope not it's the best possible
maybe the worst way to
[Laughter]
okay how do you learn if you've how do
you learn to be emotionally
vulnerable with somebody like tell them
things that you're worried they might
find out about you
and then they won't like you anymore
like there are there are slow ways you
teach people to start opening up
instead of pretending they're perfect
well i think there's a few practical
considerations
so emotionally vulnerable doesn't mean
lay everything out on the table the
first time you meet someone
you know i also tend to do that though
right
that can be you know by the way
if you are able to pass off that
emotional vulnerability with
sufficient charm you probably can get
away with it really early
but but just kind of spilling your guts
to someone you just
met and and sharing and sharing and
sharing things that maybe
they don't yet have the context for
yeah risks actually quite a lot of
misinterpretation
um and also it it kind of
does ourselves a disservice if we don't
start at least by by talking up
the things that are great about us i i
mean i sometimes i've
i don't talk very much about like you
saw how uncomfortable i am in the
introduction when you ask me
you know where have you i know the
introduction i gave myself in this
podcast
was sort of too humble
so now people who don't know me who
follow you
that's a problem don't actually realize
how great i am
but that's because of me and my i go i
like quickly shrug off like yeah i had a
new york times bestseller and millions
of people follow me and blah blah it's
like
i i'm actually in some ways doing myself
a disservice because
because it might i might have people's
ear more if i started by saying well i
did this and then this thing happened
and then this impressive thing happened
and whatever so
on a date the same thing can happen we
want to put our best foot forward
in the beginning but vulnerability as we
progress and letting people in bit by
bit
and seeing how they react to that if
someone reacts with immediate copious
amounts of judgment
then that's a bit of a red flag and if
if you point out hey that feels really
like you're judging me and that's sad
because
i was just trying to share more about
myself with you
if you communicate like that and then
they go my god you're right i'm
that sucked and i'm sorry that was just
a reflex response ah well
there's hope for these two people if
that person says well i do think
that it's blah blah blah that you did
that or that you were like then you go
okay that
this might not be my crowd so we have to
get used to the fact that if i share
something if you or i share something on
our podcasts
where a bunch of your audience says
ugh i can't belie she you know you told
us something about your past and a bunch
of people say i can't believe she did
that
unfollow then it's like okay then
then you you're not my crowd because i
i want to be around people who who can
hold space for different
parts of me and who aren't only married
to one
version of me and the same is true in
relationships i want to be
literally married to someone who's not
only married to one version of me
but someone who can hold space for the
different parts of me
now the only caveat i would add to that
is that revealing
vulnerabilities isn't the same as
constantly dumping the same
vulnerabilities on someone day after day
if we say that thing i
you know i'm struggling because i feel
unattractive
and overweight and and our partner hears
that and that's like
a beautiful moment of sharing if now
every three hours you say oh i feel
fat today oh i feel like i'm the oh i'm
now it's now it's not you're not sharing
vulnerability you're not being
vulnerable
you're just you're just ambushing
someone
constantly with your negative and
self-conscious thoughts and
the person we're with doesn't deserve
that
we have to take responsibility for
working on the things that we need to
work on
at the same time as letting our partner
in on that journey
have you ever experienced a relationship
between a man and woman
where there's jealousy about
achievements
uh yeah yeah so what's very very common
what do you do how is it by the way it's
usually it's usually the person who's
achieving a lot
who complains that their partner doesn't
you know complains you know they
complain about their partner
being uncomfortable with it but i always
think
i think every person who achieves a lot
should have to go through the experiment
of being the person in the relationship
who
as chris rock puts it in his stand up
plays tambourine
i like that yeah everyone should have to
have the run the experiment of what it
feels like to be a passenger
on somebody else's wild rocket ship
journey
um because
it it doesn't excuse us not supporting
our partners achievements
but it at the very least gives a little
perspective on
how intimidating it can be for
anyone in a situation where they're with
someone who's
on some kind of a rocket ship
and the feelings that go with that of oh
my god when they get to where they're
going are they still gonna want me
um which is a very human thing
to feel but
i think everyone should consider how
attractive
it can be when you do
support your partner's achievements even
when some of them make you uncomfortable
because they
they activate certain
traumas you have fears you have
insecurities you have if you can still
be supportive
through that that makes you a pretty
outstanding and beautiful partner
and ironically it's your best hope of
that person
wanting to stay with you i was not
expecting that answer
like what do you do with jealousy be
more humble
okay okay well i you know sometimes
sometimes
i also think that there's a lot
something that a lot of people do
who are successful is people who are
successful
an enormous number of people who are
successful are successful because of
insecurity
yes they have some demon
that that they think that if they become
successful then they'll be enough now
what that often
produces is people who are successful
and then weaponize their achievements as
a way to impress other people
so now you've got the stereotype of the
guy who
is bragging about how much money he's
made or
the woman who is really successful at
work and
never stops talking about her work and
and what she's achieved and on a date
that you know i get a lot of people say
people were really intimidated by me and
i think to myself
that may be true 100 it may be true but
we also
do have to ask ourselves am i
actually showing the full breadth of who
i am or
am i going on to a date and just hitting
someone over the head
with this thing that i get the most
attention
for because i think that whatever is the
thing you get most attention for
is kind of the thing that that is really
attractive when you don't
wear it when you can wear that lightly i
mean i think that
you know some of my my brother got a
doctorate from
oxford university and there are some
amazing people at oxford university and
there are some
unbearable people at oxford university
and you know my
my brother's friends because my brother
is a kind and humble human being
are like him and i always loved that
whenever i was around them
there's such erudite
learned people i mean they are true
true academics and you could go to lunch
with them
and they wear their knowledge so lightly
and
they're so pleasant to be around and you
feel more intelligent by being around
them
not less and i just i find that to be
such an endearing quality
when you're around someone who could
make you feel less successful by what
they've achieved
yeah they actually wear it lightly and
make you feel more successful somehow
i like that okay well the time is up
for our hour thank you very much for
coming on that was interesting it was
nice meeting you
that was lovely meeting you too i i
really enjoyed this
thank you before you go if people don't
follow you where should they go to
follow you
well actually rather than just you can
follow me on instagram or or
you know any other platform basically
youtube or whatever but there's
there's something quite practical people
can do with me right now
um in real time right now running
for thousands of people a 30-day
confidence challenge
where i'm giving away i'm literally
giving people five specific missions
they can do to improve their confidence
over 30 days
not as a kind of you know everything's
so
hyperbolic these days this isn't about
transforming your whole life in 30 days
it's about in 30 days if you do these
five things it will give you a
measurable shift in your confidence
and if people go to mhchallenge.com
they can sign up for free it's a it's a
free
blueprint i'm giving but we're all doing
it together and um you haven't missed
anything
it's coming um and uh you can start the
journey with us it's going to be
a lot of fun and it genuinely will give
people at the end of 30 days
a measurable improvement in their
confidence and momentum that can take
them into their goals for the rest of
the year
i might have to join that i'm intrigued
i'd love you too
yeah and i'd love to have you at some
point on our podcast you i
i wan my only uh
sadness of this time we've spent
together is that i
genuinely want to hear more from you um
and i
uh i hope that you'll give me the chance
to fire questions at you because i'm i'm
i love your content
and i love your your style it's unique
and it's different and it's not
it's not it has none of the hyperbole
that so much content out there has it's
grounded and it's real
and it's honest and um too many
too many compliments being thrown here
thank you very much that's really nice
to hear i will definitely talk to you on
yours amazing well thank you
you